vous désirez construire rénover aménager
votre habitat ou mettre en valeur son
environnement vous recherchez des
conseils et là il y a pléthore de
services aux particuliers
parmi ceux là existent dans chaque
département un ca eu peu ou conseil
d'architecturé d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement ces structures publiques
ont pour vocation d'informer de
sensibiliser et de conseiller les
collectivités et les particuliers
nous sommes à offrir au siège du cae du
loiret créant 80 il est composé d'une
équipe pluridisciplinaire architectes
urbanistes paysagistes et il possède un
fonds documentaire qui capitalise
l'histoire physique et sociologique du
territoire
beaucoup de collectivités le savent très
bien que la mémoire du territoire et ils
sont très souvent ils font appel à nous
sur des questions d'aménagement et on
vient avec toute l'histoire
du territoire et en même temps on est là
aussi pour réfléchir à l'avenir pour
prendre en compte les nouveaux modes de
vie on vit plus comme il ya trente ans
le conseil aux collectivités est
envisagée dans une approche globale du
paysage chaque projet est étudié sur les
plans technique bien sûr mais aussi
culturels et environnementaux
souvent on essaye d'accompagner les
collectivités
dans une réflexion je dirais d'économie
de moyens et d'objectifs durable à ça la
mode de dire ça mais mais disons que on
va faire des choses peut-être prendra du
temps peut-être on fera pas tout tout de
suite mais on essaiera de le faire au
mieux et que ce qu'ils soient faits
soient utiles pour plus tard
isabelle reçoit ce matin un couple de
particuliers qui souhaitent rénover
agrandir leurs habitants elle apporte
son regard extérieur sans contraintes
marchandes le conseil ici c'est gratuit
c'est sûr
l'organisation de la maison sur son
existant et éventuellement un deux mois
d'extension de la maison pour répondre
aux besoins avant de faire appel à un
architecte pour une étude des travaux et
de leur coup ils désirent vérifier le
bien fondé de leur projet
ils'agit ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
habite dans cette maison et on était
arrivé au bout de la réflexion et on
avait vraiment le besoin d'un
accompagnement d'un professionnel que je
vois que vous avez fait
c'est très schématique
donc ici c'est le reach c'est tout à
fait typique des questions qui se posent
à ses des interventions sur l'existant
et on en aura de plus en plus parce
qu'on ne peut plus consommer des espaces
naturels et des terres agricoles comme
on l'a fait donc on va de plus en plus
intervenir sur l'existant et ce sont
chaque fois des projets relativement
complexe et où on a besoin de
l'intervention de professionnels on
intervient très largement je crois
surtout toutes les questions on
intervient sur l'environnement sur le
patrimoine sur les questions d'énergie
on explique la réglementation on leur
fait accepter aussi dans réglementation
parce que quelquefois ils comprennent
pas bien pourquoi c'est comme ça et nous
on est là pour essayer de faire émerger
leurs envies voilà leurs besoins leurs
envies et puis après c'est sûr la
synthèse de tout ça avec leurs moyens
projets d'habitat d'hébergement
touristique ou projets d'exploitation
agricole ou commerciales chacun de nous
créer une partie du paysage
les conseils d'architecturé d'urbanisme
de l'environnement en accompagnant ces
projets proposent une amélioration
efficace des lieux de vie individuelle
dans un projet global de préservation du
paysage comme